hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
konnte wieder unter dem hashtag luca
reagiert einige videos zu setzen und
dann kamen sehr sehr sehr sehr viele
komische videos an deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht ich laufe immer wieder ein paar
runter und zeigt ihr euch und reagiert
darauf
da ist jetzt also dieses mädchen was das
ganze film wie zwei jungs also zwei
freunde von ihr auf der
gegenüberliegenden seite von diesem
schluss aus sonnen- oder plattformen
stehen
sie hat mir nimmt wieder zugeschrieben
dass ihr freund zeigen wollte wie stabil
denn diese brücke ist was hat es mit
jackson rudi auf jeden fall eine ganz
starke leistung du willst du den leuten
zeigen ich dass wir diese dinge worauf
du dich bewegst und fällst einfach
runter mein respekt hast du kommen wir
nun zu den nächsten video mit falls ihr
ständig kennt der kann eben video dieser
reihe vorgaben schon monatelang nicht
mehr diese videos ziel gemacht wo ich
auf eure videos reagiere
deswegen sind seitdem wahrscheinlich
schon viele neue abonnenten dazu
gekommen also ist es mittlerweile so
martin geck dass er jeden mal wo ich
sage schickte videos zu kommt er mit
einem lebensmittel an was er mir sagt
bitter und die letzten male war das
eigentlich immer tomatensaft war das
sehen wir auch so ein running gag ich
musste mich erklären wie tomatensaft ich
weiß nicht mehr selber wie tomatensaft
entstanden das apropos tomatensaft
niveau der letzten liter zugeschrieben
sie sind wirklich ein love you more than
torwand
billig ultra coole von dir werde einfach
wie sorbit geschrieben höher diesen
scheiß tomatensaft zweiten video also
leute auf unsere community ich glaube
ich echt keiner toppen alles klar die
ganzen video natürlich jetzt kommen
immer katzen videos wenn ich auf eure
videos reagiere aber okay wir schauen
uns an was hier passiert okay das
erstmals also die katze hat gelernt wenn
sie auf die flügel drückt das ihnen
leckerli bekommen finde das richtig
trans wenn tiere irgendwelche tricks
drauf haben zum beispiel kumpel von mir
hatte damals haube auf seinem arm also
nicht immer aber er konnte dass ihr
wisst was ich meine aber den consultant
auf seinem arm haben und trotzdem nicht
nützen und ist eine runde geflogen kam
dann wieder auf seinen haben ich weiß
nicht ob die auch mal bei ihm aufnahmen
geschossen hat oder so aber das fand ich
immer sehr cool wir schauen aber mal wie
das video weitergeht
also es ist quasi wirklich sondern halbe
minuten video holen eine katze auf eine
klingel drückte ein leckerli bekommen
trotzdem danke für die einsendung stimmt
dass das sinn oder bei den eltern bist
mikrofasertücher mit dusche nimmst damit
er keine kalkflecken reinkommen was
dusche nimmst damit keine kalten
reinkommen was ich verstehe die frage
irgendwie ist sogar also sie hat gefragt
ob ich dabei meine eltern bin und auch
das stimmt dass ich mikrofasertücher
benutzt die umstände keine kalten beim
elektro bis man etwas runter gefallen
hat
korrekt leute finde ich auch richtig
cool eben büchergeschäft mein buch nach
hinten
nicht euer ernst also sie hatten ihr im
video was raus getrunken und die danach
hingeschmissen hat ist die stehen
geblieben denn es kann ja schon lange ok
ich frag mal nicht nach was ihr euch
dabei denk mir so verschicken als
nächste video ist dieses hier
ich spreche es ja gerade schon ab
allerdings ohne ton bei den ton hören
würde würde die recht aufregen wieso hat
seinen hintergrund einer gekotzt also
ich hab das video erst mal twitter
gesehen und wollen sie nicht mit
reinnehmen bald dachte okay das mädel 50
macht nicht mal etwas außergewöhnliches
aber im hintergrund trotzdem wie einer
guckt mal was ich selbst gemacht habe
okay du hast dir übels viele hier sind
dies luca shop gibt irgendwie selbst
gemacht bitte halten
es kreist wenn du demnächst für die
beschaffung die arbeiten möchte es dann
schreibt eine mail man kann solche leute
immer gebrauchen sie hat mir dazu den
tweet geschrieben dass sie alle sind
nicht erlaubt am kittel zu kaufen
deswegen hat sie sich die ganze selber
gemacht aber trotzdem megatrucks aktion
bei den nächsten video haben wir diesen
jungen und ihr seht schon der vierte
eine flasche und ich hab das wieder die
ganze zeit in we play laufen weil das
was danach passiert ist sehr interessant
und einfach nur atemberaubend übel gut
dich du hast dich drauf zeigt euch mal
wie das bei mir aussehen würde
wow
ich meine wenigstens hast du noch mal
ein mensch dabei an
nein
korrekter magic trip so wird das ganze
bei mir aussehen könnte jetzt nicht die
mich und gleichzeitig den himmel also
das was ihr vom video meine damen und
herren ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
werde ich das getan hat werde man
leichter ihr findet hier oben einen
smiley eigene trennen wenn ihr das
hoffen könnte meinen kanal abonnieren
und ihr findet ihr ein video
eingeblendet wo ich das schon mal
gemacht haben also schauen wir auf
videos reagiert habe
haut rein